[Music]  in our stories the tan is quite content  to stay in the shadows or behind the  camera so to speak  but it's a magical origin story and as  zatanna starts coming to her magic she's  also to have to step into the limelight  rosie is deeply moody introspective  thoughtful loving and has really strong  connections with her friends  i had a lot of fun uh  drawing her teenager attitude lots of  eye rolling  so tana and her whole group are kind of  all like a little gang of weirdos coney  island is such a deeply special place  in real life and jacqueline did an  amazing job bringing it to life  my favorite thing was designing the  curiosity shop because it's just full of  weird items i think of mermaids when i  think of you when we have so many  mermaids on coney island yeah mermaids  too  so much of zatanna's story is a  father-daughter story and  father-daughter stories never get old i  hope that it inspires a lot of younger  girls to be themselves  [Music]  you